[Music]
you'll be trained in psychological
manipulation are we going to become
France is Lau one
[Music]
I saw something I wasn't supposed to
there's another life for you if you
wanted from this day forward you will
become sparrows you'll be trained in
psychological manipulation when we are
finished with you the person you were
will no longer exist this is what you
want men to talk then everybody goes
find a way red Sparrow Morty honey mama
what is it
I have to go with Roy
I was told to take a man to hotel I said
that he was an enemy of the state take
off your dress
and in exchange my mother look at the
doctor she made him instead they cut his
throat
there could be no witnesses so they gave
me a choice die or become a sparrow from
this day forward you will become
space-weapons in a global struggle for
power you'll be trained in psychological
manipulation we must learn to push
yourself beyond all limitation take off
your clothes when we are finished with
you the person you were will no longer
exist every human being is a puzzle of
need you must become the missing piece
and they will tell you anything you have
a gift you know how to survive this is
what you were meant to talk
there is a traitor in the government his
last known contact is an American good
clothes I'm a very say in the pool
yesterday are we going to become friends
say what you want
it's a sparrow the only America's of
what you could do for them work with me
and make this man pay you are better
this than any of us your only problem is
you have a soul
we can't trust a word that comes out of
her mouth there's something else or
nothing
the fees compromised she will be
eliminated what have you done
you belong to them they won't ever let
go I'll find a way
you
you